i don't think it's any secret to anyone
that water is essential to life most of
the biological or actually frankly all
of the significant biological processes
in your body are dependent on water and
are probably occurring inside of water
when you think of the cells in your body
the cytoplasm inside of your cells that
is mainly water in fact me who's talking
to you right now i am 60 to 70 percent
water you can think of me as kind of
this big bag of water
making a video right now and it's not
just human beings that need water life
as we know it is dependent on water
that's why when we have the search for
for signs of life on other planets we're
always looking for signs of water maybe
life can occur in other types of in
other types of substances but water is
what is essential to life as we know it
and to understand why water is so
special let's start to understand the
structure of water and how it interacts
with itself
and so water
water is you probably already know is
made up of one oxygen atom and two
hydrogen atoms
and two hydrogen atoms that's why we
call it h2o
h2o and they are bonded with covalent
bonds and covalent bonds each of these
bonds this is a pair of electrons that
both of these atoms get to pretend like
they have
and so you have these two pairs and you
might be saying well why did i draw the
two hydrogens on this end why didn't i
draw them
on opposite sides of the oxygen well
that's because oxygen also has two lone
electron pairs
two lone electron pairs
and these things are always repelling
each other the electrons are repelling
from each other and so in reality if we
were looking at three dimensions the
oxygen molecule is kind of a tetrahedral
a tetrahedral shape i could try to let
me try to draw it a little bit so if
this is the oxygen right over here then
you would have you could have maybe one
lone pair of electrons i'll draw it as a
little green circle there another lone
pair of electrons back here then you
have the covalent bond you have the
covalent bond to
one hydrogen atom
one hydrogen atom right over there and
then you have the covalent bond and then
you have the covalent bond to the other
hydrogen atom and so you see it forms
this this
this tetrahedral shape it's pretty close
to a tetrahedron
just like this but the key is that the
hydrogens are on one end of the molecule
and this is we're going to see very very
important to the unique properties or to
the the what gives water its special
properties now one thing to realize is
you know it's very in chemistry we draw
these electrons very neatly these dots
up here we draw these covalent bonds
very neatly but that's not the way that
it actually works electrons are jumping
around constantly they're buzzing around
it's actually much more of a
even when you think about electrons it's
more of a probability of where you might
find them and so instead of thinking of
these electrons as you know definitely
here or definitely in these bonds
they're actually more of in this cloud
around the different atoms they're in
this cloud that kind of describes a
probability of where you might find them
as they buzz and they and they jump
around
and what's interesting about water
is oxygen is extremely electronegative
so oxygen that's oxygen that's oxygen it
is extremely electronegative it's one of
the more electronegative
elements we know of it's definitely way
more electronegative than hydrogen and
you might be saying well what does it
what does it mean to be electronegative
well electronegative is just a fancy way
of saying
it's just a fancy way of saying that it
hogs electrons
hogs electrons it likes to keep
electrons for itself
hogs
hogs electrons so that's what's that's
what's going on oxygen likes to keep the
electrons more around itself than the
partners that it's bonding with so even
in these covalent bonds you could you
say hey we're supposed to be sharing
these electrons oxygen says well i still
want them to spend a little bit more
time with me and so they actually do
spend more time on the side without the
hydrogens than they do around the
hydrogens and you could imagine what
this is going to do this is going to
form a partial negative charge at the i
guess you could say the non-hydrogen end
this the end that has that that's well i
guess this this top end the way i've
drawn it right over here and this greek
letter delta this is to signify a
partial charge and it's a partial
negative charge because electrons are
negative and then over here since you
have a slight deficiency of electrons
because they're spending so much time
around the oxygen it forms a partial
positive charge
partial positive charge right over there
so right when you just look at one
one water molecule that doesn't seem so
interesting but it becomes really
interesting when you look at many water
molecules interacting together so let me
draw another water molecule right over
here
so it's oxygen you have two hydrogens
and then you have the bonds between them
you have a partially negative charge
there partially positive charge on that
end and so you can imagine the partial
the the side that has a partially
negative charge is going to be attracted
to the side that has a partially
positive charge and that attraction that
that between these two this is called a
hydrogen bond
so that right over there is called a
hydrogen bond
and this is key to the behavior of water
and we're going to see that in future
videos all the different ways that
hydrogen bonds give water its unique
characteristics hydrogen bonds are
weaker than covalent bonds but they're
strong enough to give water that kind of
nice
fluid nature when we're thinking about
kind of normal where you'd say normal
temperatures and
and pressures this nice fluid nature it
allows these things to to be attracted
to each other to have some cohesion but
also to break and reform and flow past
each other so you can imagine another
hydrogen bond with another water
molecule
another water molecule right over here
so put my hydrogens over there
put my hydrogens here bonds partial
negative
partial
partial positive right over there and so
we'll see in future videos hydrogen
bonds key for water flowing past itself
key for its its properties to its
ability to to take in heat key for its
ability to regulate temperature the key
for its abilities why why lakes don't
freeze over it's key for some of its
properties around around evaporative
cooling and and surface tension and
adhesion and cohesion and we'll see that
and and probably most important is hard
to rank of these things if we're
thinking about biological systems this
this polarity that we have in water
molecules and these hydrogen bonding
it's key for its ability to be a solvent
for it to be able to to to have polar
molecules be dissolved inside of water
and we'll see that in future videos